lors de l'audience doc gynéco a reconnu
les faits et il a bien donné quatre
giflé et insulté sa femme avec laquelle
il était en couple depuis 25 ans elle a
d'abord évoqué un coup de sang face aux
policiers devant le juge
doc gynéco a finalement reconnu d'autres
violences plus anciennes ses enfants et
sa femme évoquent quant à eux des
violences habituelles
finalement le chanteur a été condamné à
cinq mois d'emprisonnement et 2000 euros
damende sa peine a été de plus assortie
d'un sursis probatoire de trois ans
pendant lesquels doc gynéco devra suivre
un stage sur les violences conjugales ne
pas se rendre au domicile de sa femme et
ne pas entrer en contact avec elle sa
femme qui a entamé une procédure de
divorce
alors pour cette réforme sera la femme
du chanteur à la femme de doc gynéco
merci m khalifa d'être avec no mercy
jonathan qu'elle nous a en prime ce qui
s'est passé le 10 mars dernier parce que
c'est vrai que doc
c'était un proche de nous on était cuit
et c'est vrai que je vous dire la vérité
nous on était très proche de lui on
l'adoré vraiment on était vraiment
c'était notre chouchou parlait déjà de
lui au passé
non non non mais non mais c'est à dire
quand il était dans la bien sûr la
savoie là et c'est vrai qu'on a plus
nouvelle du jour au lendemain on n'a pas
compris ce qui s'était passé un moment
je vous dis la vérité je pensais qu'il
avait été influencé par des personnes
qu'ils étaient sous influence de pâques
une secte mais de vraiment de personnes
qui lui disait plus nous parler et je le
vois là et ça nous a fait beaucoup de
peine à toute l'équipe
c'est pas le cas du tout non je n'étais
pas du tout le cas y'a pas de secte il
ya rien d r jean et qu il n'y a pas de
de ce genre de méfaits là ce que je peux
vous dire sur la journée du 10 mars
évidemment je peux me contenter de vous
dire les choses qui sont sortis que de
choses qui sont publiques
la journée du 10 là sur la soirée du 10
mars donc
des violences ont été il ya eu des
violences un acte de violence les ponts
les laisser le sont les voisins qui ont
appelé la police
la police a été donc requise elle est
venue assez déplacé et sans le moindre
difficulté donc à ce moment là bruno
vous connaissez donc a été placé en
garde à vue mais sans la moindre
difficulté une interpellation qui se
passe évidemment très normalement
messieurs et conduit monsieur beau syrie
d'être conduits au poste de police
il va faire l'objet d'une garde à vue ça
c'était effectivement
c'est est ressorti donc à paris ce qu'il
était il était sous lens de produits de
alors je peux vous dire c'est
extrêmement simple ça ressort du dossier
chaque personne qui en garde à vue
lorsqu'il ya des violences lors s'il ya
des liens avec aussi des produits
stupéfiants n'importe quoi ce qu'on va
faire ce qu'on va faire un dépistage
urinaire oui et on va faire un dépistage
urinaire sur doc gynéco et je vous le
dis le dépistage urinaire sur toutes les
substances tester il est négatif à tous
d'accord également sur les pros sur
l'alcool
il est négatif attaquants on va essayer
non bien sûr il s'agit de claire
évidemment pouvoir etc sont bien sûr
dire clairement les choses cette
question qu'on se pose évidemment je
comprends pas d'ailleurs la justice se
l'est posée c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est réquisition d'un médecin
pour qu'il puisse faire d'un dépistage
urinaire et le résultat est arrivé là au
cours de la garde à vue et tout
effectivement immédiatement avoué les
faits de ce conseil il a reconnu les
faits dès le dso interpellation il ya eu
aucune contestation de sa part je tiens
à dire qu'il n'a aucunement il cherchait
à aucunement minimiser son implication
voilà hilali s'est expliquée sur les
faits assez longuement sur deux
auditions ce sont des gardes à vue a été
relativement longue
on a été on a écoulé presque le temps
possible dans une de la garde à vue de
droit commun c'est-à-dire 48 heures il a
fait l'objet d'une garde à vue donc de
deux jours et après il a été donc
présenté un juge qui l'a placé sous
contrôle judiciaire avec des obligations
dans le cadre de ses obligations en
avait plusieurs il les a toutes
respectées en attendant l'audience qui
s'est passé donc comme vous savez la
semaine dernière sa compagne n'a pas
souhaité porter plainte pourquoi c'est
un choix qui relèvent évidemment de sa
libre appréciation
sachez je pense qu'on le dit assez sur
les plateaux et on peut le répéter n'y a
pas de difficultés au contraire c'est
bien de le répéter que la plainte n'est
pas nécessaire lorsque pour poursuivre
une personne très bien sûr lorsqu'il
s'agit de faits de violence c'est la
première fois que ça arrive et monsieur
coué gynéco un beau dossier on va dire
il a un casier complètement vierge est
la première fois qu il ya il ya eu des
faits de violences au casier est
complètement vierge de toute forme de
violence antérieurs et il n'avait jamais
fait l'objet d'une garde à vue de la
sorte
selon mes informations si la garde à vue
a été aussi longue c'est quand même
qu'il ya eu des déclarations
contradictoires de doc gynéco d'abord il
a plaidé le coup de sang puis sa femme
et deux de ses filles ont dit les
violences sont habituelles il a reconnu
sale habitude
et après au procès il a dit non non
c'est un coup de sang une seule fois est
ce que c'est vrai que les violences
étaient récurrentes mais alors
je vais vous expliquer ce qu'il en est
sur ce point j'attendais évidemment
cette question là comme je voudrais de
vous expliqué le parquet qui sait on va
dire auto saisie de l'affairé qui a
décidé de poursuivre doc gynéco donc
pour des faits de violence des violences
commises donc le 10 mars au terme de la
prévention le 10 mars 2021 au fil de la
garde à vue
il dit qu'il y avait des éléments qui a
pour être contradictoires à la fin de la
garde à vue qui a eu ce qu'on appelle
l'orientation du parquet le parquet
décide de poursuivre monsieur uniquement
sur les faits de violence
ce jour là s'il y avait dans le dossier
des éléments permettant de retenir parce
que c'est là qu'elle c'est l'orientation
du parquet c'est lui qui décide
effectivement de poursuivre l'individu
il aurait pu poursuivre ce qu'on appelle
les violences habituelles sur conjoint
c'est une autre forme de de répression
et c'est une forme de sanction et c'est
effectivement pas le choix qu'a des
suites du parquet pourquoi parce qu'on
n'était plus effectivement sur les
violences
uniquement sur le 10 mars alors dans
l'affairé il a parlé d'une bêtise il est
conscient de la gravité des faits ou pas
pleinement sommes pleinement pleinement
beaucoup de réflexion beaucoup de c'est
toujours effectivement très compliqué de
se retrouver dans cette situation
las de devoir faire face à ça il l'a
fait il à pouilly la plus je vous le dis
dans le cas de son contrôle judiciaire
avec obligation de voir un médecin
psychologue ça arrive c'est pas propre à
doc gynéco on le fait pour tout tir de
personnes qui font l'objet d'un contrôle
judiciaire on leur met une obligation de
soins souvent quand ils sont pour des
faits de violence et il a respecté le
som d'obligations il a vu un médecin
cela permet aussi d'avoir un peu de
réflexion sur ce qu'il a fait et c'est
ça je pense vraiment le plus important
et c'est ce qui à mon avis est peut être
une forme de craintes pour la justice
par moments pour cette percée pour
certaines personnes déguisées - comment
violence conjugale c'est qu'on doit
vraiment être sûr que la panne a bien
compris de quoi il s'agissait
les risques qui est encouru et c'était
aussi l'intérêt de ce contrôle
judiciaire
et ça a permis je pense à l'audience de
pouvoir bien expliquer la situation soit
ça s'accompagne aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas en mesure de voir moi je représente
la beaussière j'espère qu'elle va bien
il a été condamné à une peine de cinq
mois de prison avec sursis total il a
compris cette peine il trouve que c'est
une peine lourde oui confond alors c'est
une décision de justice qui est
évidemment il faut respecter et faire
appel non alors on est toujours dans le
délai d'appel mais la décision
évidemment nous revient à tous les deux
pour le moment enfin surtout à lui et
ses mots avec son conseil pour le moment
on n'est pas sur une décision d'appel
effectivement pourquoi parce que c'est
une peine qui je pense peut évidemment
l'aider également à s'en sortir et
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il a fait et
pouvoir le but de 2,2 tout ce qu'il ya
c'est de ces deux le tribunal a assorti
cette peine d'une d'un sursis probatoire
de trois ans tout à fait dire que
pendant trois ans qu'est-ce qu'il aura
le droit terre et pas faire il a alors
pendant trois ans enfin sursis
probatoire ce que c'est il a une peine
au dessus de sa tête ça aussi reste
chaque mois tout à fait de cinq mois
d'emprisonnement s'ils respectent
l'ensemble des obligations avant qu'on
va lui fixé que je vais vous énoncez
tout de suite pendant trois ans c'est
bon il y aura pas de souci leur école a
franchi au fait de la justice ont loire
à vis des obligations les aura respecté
alors on peut angie team en dire le lieu
la confiance pour pouvoir mieux se
comporter effectivement c'est le
principe du sursis probatoire
c'est quoi cette obligation les
obligations il s'agit donc de continuer
son obligation de soins il était
volontaire de voir je sais pas quelle
fréquence exactement ça va se mettre en
place qu'ils puissent continuer à un
suivi qui puissiez ville écologique ou
psychologique
comment s'est effectivement souvent le
cas lorsqu'il s'agit de genre de faits
là il va y avoir il va aussi
il a également été condamné excusez moi
à l'obligation de suivre un stage de
citoyenneté sur les violences faites aux
femmes
corps à ses frais il va alors lui même
prendre attache avec un organisme pour
faire cette semaine se poursuivre cet ce
stage qui je pense pour être bénéfique
et l'ensemble des personnes qui sont en
général condamné permettent effet que ce
stage permet effectivement des fois de
comprendre un peu les choses et d'être
confronté à d'autres personnes dans la
même situation est peut-être plus facile
aussi d'échanger à ce moment là et
d'autres obligations l'interdiction
effectivement de se rendre au domicile
de sa femme est donc en contact avec sa
femme et ses enfants pour aller voir
oui il était à aucune distinction il n'y
a pas de vie n'est pas en procès avec
ses enfants il est il et dans quelles
dispositions aujourd'hui par rapport à
par rapport à tout ce qui se passe par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé est ce
qu'il est dans je pense qu'il préfère
parce que effectivement il y avait une
invitation qui était de venir avec lui
il a pris la décision à juste titre je
pense d'eux plutôt essayer de s'isoler
pour le moment encore continuer un peu
la réflexion qui était la sienne sur les
faits qui qu'il a commis et qu'il a
seulement pas contester ni minimiser
merci ben khalifa oui sa femme a bien
demandé le divorce
je sais je sais ce qui est sûr qui sait
ce qui est sorti mais je pourrais pas
vous dire moi je suis un avocat j'ai pas
été saisie en tout cas de cette demande
là mais je pense pas je vous le dis
qu'on aura vocation à s'exprimer sur le
divorce on ou d'objets niko ça relève
comme la vie privée je pense que peu de
personnes veulent effectivement qu'on
débatte leur vie conjugale et la marée
noire de ce public mais je peux pas les
flamands de là ils parlent d'un coup de
sang est-ce qu'à une échelle de valeur
sur le coup de sang parce que 19 jours
d'itt et et d oedème au visage et des
hématomes baisse quand on considérait
que sa femme
c'est une femme battue tout simplement
ah oui bien sûr la journée du 10 mars
mais est ce qu'on peut considérer duc
apparemment ses habitants est ce que ces
noms de femmes n'as-tu pas sur l'instant
mais vous régulièrement battu ya parce
que je vous convie choisi c'est pas des
violences qui sont habituelles comme
l'un de vous dire que la violence qui
sont passés uniquement le 10 mars
dernier et sur les jours d'itt et et que
je vous explique
ça saute 4,4 juifs dans un visage d'une
femme des hématomes des oedèmes 19 jours
d'itt et est ce que cette expérience je
pense à ce qui va vous expliquer si vous
voulez bien y'a pas de soucis comme
j'étais dans le dossier je vous
expliquais il s'agit en fait de cinq
jours d'itt et et qui sont des hits et
et physiques qui sont liées
effectivement voilà
beaucoup qui ont été portées donc cinq
jours d'itt été et à côté de ça on a un
retentissement psychologique et c'est
les dix neuf des quinze jours dont on
parle et c'est effectivement un
retentissement juste psychologique sur
je pense sur la situation sur aussi une
année 2020 mais j'imagine pour plein de
gens compliqué sur l'enfant de ses fans
à sa fin bien sûr que c'est skype et ils
sont aussi très important parce que y'a
retentissement psychologique très
important
merci m jonathan khalifa d'avoir été
avec nos avocats de doc gynéco on espère
que sa compagne va se remettre et que
furtivement là ça commence conscience de
la gravité c'est déjà fait et va
continuer de le faire et j'espère qu'il
pourra venir avec va prochainement dans
l'émission je vais vous dire quelque
chose d'autre gynéco il était bien mieux
et il avait je pense qu'il était sur le
bon chemin quand il était avec nous ah
oui et c'est vrai que ça me fait de la
peine moi de voir de tels agissements
parce que c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit là
qu'on apprécie beaucoup qui a un coeur
énorme et qui est tombé dans les travers
qu'on n'avait pas vu ici dans l'émission
et qui nous font énormément de peine non
seulement surtout pour sa compagne mais
aussi pour lui parce que et c'est
quelqu'un je pense qu'ils voilà qui qui
qui est mal entourée voilà je pensais
qu'il était très bien j'espère non mais
franchement rencontré en tout